what our teachers lacking now is that  that they're not motivated is that they  don't know the subject is that that they  don't know how to actually get her act  with students I think it's a variety of  things I mean I remember you know as a  classroom teacher you you really feel  like the whole system is working against  you so instead of having the work that's  happening at your school administration  level or your district administration  level supporting what you're doing and  making what you're what you're trying to  accomplish easier or more effective it  actually feels like those things are  holding you back and that is the  complete opposite of the way that our  system ought to be working